[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 14 septembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 60,18 voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
attrape deux anciens opposants s'allient
pour l'élection municipale partielle
l'ex maire guy malandain annonce
rejoindre othman nzru pour le scrutin
des dix sept 17 octobre prochain rendu
nécessaire après l'annulation des
résultats de 2020 par le conseil d'état
le détail à suivre depuis ce lundi il
sillonne les yvelines le bus jobs
insertion a été lancée par le
département son objectif aider les
demandeurs d'emploi dans les quartiers
où le chômage est élevé première étape
hier à mantes la ville et puis la plus
grande reconstitution historique de
l'époque de napoléon 1er elle s'est
déroulée ce week end au château de
versailles là où les curators l'empereur
un événement à l'occasion du
bicentenaire de sa mort un anniversaire
dans ce journal celui de la ferme du
mana et qui a fêté ses 30 ans ce week
end à montigny le bretonneux et de la
musique également avec les halls factory
festival qui était de retour à mantes la
jolie
[Musique]
mais d'abord donc ce nouveau
rebondissement à trappes en vue de
l'élection municipale partielle guy
malandain s'associer à la candidature
d'hotman nzru pour ce scrutin au
programme les 10 et 17 octobre prochains
c'est une information tv 78 l ancien
maire de la ville en poste depuis en
poste pendant 19 ans part donc avec son
ex opposant au conseil municipal entre
2014 et 2020 qui fait équipe une
nouvelle fois avec mustapha larbaoui un
trio donc pour faire face à ali rabais
dont l'élection de 2020 a été invalidée
par le conseil d'état et guy malandain
n'indique pas en revanche pour le moment
à quelle place il figurera sur cette
liste d'union écoutez ses explications
recueillies par bixente mayence insisté
ban nous formons une liste républicaine
démocratique et honnête nous sommes
trois têtes de liste si je puis dire
travailler sur un programme en forme
nous avons travaillé sur la constitution
du lys dans la situation difficile
et il me touche profondément dans
laquelle et rap nous avons vraiment
monter une liste de gens extrêmement
bien joué à la cause publique a lâché
sur ma victoire
el fakih est essentielle et face à guy
malandain et manas roues et mustapha
larbaoui ali rabat est également en lice
tout comme luc miserait pour trappe à
gauche patrick plan pour lutte ouvrière
aussi et robert et ronsard anna garrity
nam qui apporte la liste ensemble pour
l'environnement et l'économie solidaire
et dans l'actualité de ce mardi triple
visite ministérielle à elancourt
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie et les secrétaires
d'état sophie cluzel et olivia grégoire
et et au site est d'airbus défense n
space est déplacement sur le thème des
salariés dans une mission spéciale de la
plateforme rse pour responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises nous
reviendrons plus largement sur cette
information dans notre jt de demain
mercredi
chercher un travail au pas de sa porte
ce sera désormais possible avec le bus
jobs d'insertion le département a lancé
lundi ce véhicule itinérant dans les
yvelines qui s'arrêtera est là où le
chômage est élevé ou dans les zones
isolées et ce afin d'aider les
demandeurs d'emploi le reportage de
bixente magnan santisteva un bus high
tech pour aider les demandeurs d'emploi
et accompagner les entreprises à
recruter le département a présenté ce
lundi 13 septembre le bus jobs insertion
à nantes la ville une première commune
pas choisi au hasard montre la ville
est une ville qui est en difficulté au
niveau de l'emploi et le bus insertion
dont est effectivement donc le bienvenu
ici quand nous on s'inscrit dans les
deux à la fois donc ville étendue et une
ville avec la nécessité de l'insertion
et
on change d'emploi le projet mené par l'
agence d'insertion départementale
activity pôle emploi et les missions
locales des yvelines souhaite aller au
devant des demandeurs d'emploi en
s'installant dans les quartiers
aujourd'hui d'un grand département
territorialement très étendue il y à des
personnes en situation sociale difficile
qu'ils en ont pas de moyens de mobilité
qui ne peuvent donc pas se rendre dans
les lieux où ils sont susceptibles de
trouver un emploi dix-huit communes ont
été choisies pour un premier tour d'un
mois jusqu'au 8 octobre avec en moyenne
trois passages par ville c'est le
principe assez il faut que ça revienne
régulièrement puisque en fait le marché
du travail vous avez vu est très
dynamique en ce moment mais
malheureusement le marché de le chômage
est aussi très dynamique et donc il faut
qu'on touche très très régulièrement les
demandeurs d'emploi et les bénéficiaires
du rsa parmi les cibles préférentielles
de l'opération la jeunesse c'est une
nécessité effectivement on a parfois des
entreprises qui est cherche des
candidats on a des candidats mais qui
sont à l'autre bout des yvelines et
parfois sans moyen de transport donc
c'est vraiment essentiel de pouvoir
travailler sur ce cette question de la
mobilité entre espace d'accueil de
conseil ou encore d'informatique en
libre service le coût du véhicule
s'élève à hauteur de 378 1000 euros
financés par le département
économie toujours direction saint nom la
bretèche la ferme horticole they are est
transformé en incubateur agricole elle
héberge aujourd'hui 8 start up de la l2
la grille tech et de la foux tech la
découverte avec nicolas landry s'est
décalé delà du souci c'est une plante
est très utilisé en cosmétique une
plante utilisée pour la régénération de
la peau et la particularité ici elle est
cultivée sur une tour métallique
la spécialité de la start up to wear
farm une ferme en salle blanche pour
cultiver différents types de plantes la
tourelle et elle est dans sa position
verticale elle tourne sur elle-même pour
avoir une rotation sur 24 heures comme
ça chaque plante a exactement les mêmes
conditions
de climat et d'environnement ça permet
d'avoir des conditions climatiques
complètement contrôlé et donc de
produire des plantes qui ne pourraient
pas être produits dans nos régions ou
alors de produire des plantes avec une
très grosse qualité ça va viser la
création de compléments alimentaires par
exemple ou de cosmétiques
tower farm fait partie des start-up
accueilli ici à saint nom la bretèche
entre l'horticulture et l'incubation il
n'y a qu'un pas il a été franchi par la
ferme horticole they are spécialisée
dans la production d'herbes aromatiques
biologiques
aujourd'hui elle héberge aussi 8 start
up nous accueillons les start up pour
qu'elles viennent y faire leurs preuves
de concept et jusqu'à leur phase
première usine première chaîne de
montage autre start-up incubés ici la
société bliss etc ospreys elle développe
une technologie destinée à la
pulvérisation des produits dans les
vignes et cette forme de
l'europe qui pulvérise de soul de l'air
et qui donc permet de confiner les
gouttelettes qui sont plus bel intérieur
dans une zone en forme de tunnel est
également d'agiter la vigne au passage
du colonisateur pour améliorer la
répartition du produit qui sont
pulvérisés dans la vie on s'attendait à
une meilleure mobilité de de la
pulvérisation et ça a aussi montré que
on arrivait à réduire drastiquement la
quantité de produit qui est perdu dans
l'environnement pour la ferme horticole
tr l'activité d'incubation a commencé en
2010 est son ambition devenir un
véritable cluster de l'agriculture
technologique
parlons à présent de ce concours le 4.0
mobility challenge lancé par là sauf toi
république c'est cette association est
de six grands groupes industriels pour
développer une mobilité connectée
durable dont fait partie renault qui est
implanté notamment dans les yvelines à
guyancourt ça a été lancée le 6
septembre start-up entrepreneurs et
instituts de recherche peuvent
s'inscrire jusqu'au 13 octobre nicolas
d'andré a rencontré le directeur
opérationnel de ce programme pour
renault groupe c les gars de son goût
pour les moyens techniques la software
république une initiative lancée en
avril 2021 par cinq groupes industriels
rejoint depuis peu par l'opérateur
orange pour en parler nous sommes avec
eric quintin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur opérationnel de la software
république pour le groupe renault
puisque la software république est à
l'initiative du groupe renault juste
rappeler quel est le principe de cette
association industrielle
le principe il est simple quand le cadet
mais où notre
p dg a lancé le plan rhône olsen il a
donné une ambition groupe renault de
devenir une compagnie de technologie
intel compagnie c'est une ambition bien
sûr qui va loin et pour arriver là
l'idée c'était qu'on pouvait pas le
faire tout seul parce que la tête parce
que les mobilités parce que les services
c'est finalement une question
d'écosystèmes et donc on a besoin
d'assembler des compétences de plusieurs
acteurs et c'est comme ça que finalement
on a réuni à atos dassault systèmes
orange stmicroelectronics et thales qui
finalement ont des activités très
complémentaires dans le monde de la
mobilité pour créer
ces software et
les outils de la mobilité de demain
voilà donc c'est une initiative très
concrète et depuis le mois d'avril les
équipes des six entreprises sont au
travail ensemble pour générer des
projets alors les équipes travaillent
déjà et là on franchit une nouvelle
étape puisque le 6 septembre vous avez
lancé le 4.0 mobility challenge les
inscriptions ont commencé le 6 septembre
et vont jusqu'au 13 octobre est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer en quoi
consiste ce challenge on est parti du
constat que nous on avait plein de
compétences dans les six groupes je vais
en citer néanmoins on a aussi besoin de
s'alimenter de l'esprit entrepreneurial
des idées des initiatives de plus
petites structures tous les
entrepreneurs les start up et c est donc
pour se nourrir de sa et les faire
collaborer on s'est dit que notre
meilleur atout c'est est de partager les
données que les différents groupes ou
sur différentes chaînes vecteur de la
mobilité pour finalement permettre de
développer des nouveaux services et donc
c'est ce qu'on propose donc depuis
effectivement quelques jours il ya déjà
un grand nombre de candidatures qui sont
arrivés on a les ddd des start up ou des
étudiants où il ya notamment des
collaborateurs aussi des grands groupes
qui peuvent proposer des projets sur la
base de données qu'on leur fournit ça ça
dure jusqu'au 13 octobre à partir de là
non refaire une première sélection des
dix projets qui nous semblent les plus
prometteurs en terme de
transformation de la mobilité et
d'opportunités de deux business
puisqu'on est là quand même pour créer
de la valeur et à partir de là ensuite
pendant tout le mois de novembre ces
start-up ou ces entrepreneurs seront
accompagnés par les experts des
différents groupes ce qui est quand même
extrêmement précieux pour eux afin de
prototyper et d'arrivée avec une sirène
propositions concrètes me descendre et
là on aura le grand jury avec un certain
nombre de dix raids dirigeants de nos
groupes pour choisir les grands gagnants
qui a eu ensuite bénéficieront d'une
incubation dans la sauveteuse république
il mais bénéficieront d'une exposition
en matière de communication dans des
grands salons tech voilà donc on et puis
surtout on l'espère de business avec les
grands groupes donc finalement ce ce
challenge moi j'appelle ça c'est 6 pour
le prix d'un vous participer à un
challenge est derrière en fait vous avez
accès à six leaders européens
de la mobilité voilà pour le calendrier
qu'est ce que on attend dans le fond
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent les six groupes dans le
fond quel type de projet on pourrait
voir émerger alors c'est la mobilité
c'est très large on peut être dans la
voiture on peut être en dehors de la
voiture je pense que
on peut donner des exemples part
très concret dans le quotidien on pense
par exemple la question du parking on
sait qu'en ville le temps que mettent
les gens à se garer peut être une source
de perte de temps pour eux de co2 émis
de congestion pour essentiellement à
partir des données on doit pouvoir
optimiser ses parcours pour les clients
de la même manière on peut
imaginer que si on plaît on agrège des
données qui viennent de plein de
secteurs différente puisque entre orange
thalès renault finalement on couvre
plein de d'opérations différentes de
mobiliser dans la ville eh bien on va
être capable de mieux planifier de mieux
intégrer les différentes modes mode de
transport est d'avoir une planification
plus intelligente et plus efficace
puisque on sait que les villes elles
cherchent beaucoup d'efficacité dans la
mobilité tant en termes d'émissions
qu'en termes de temps passé par leurs
usagers vous parlez d'incubation l'idée
c'est de laisser quand même une certaine
marge à ces entrepreneurs parce que la
peur de certains entrepreneurs dans ce
type d'initiative c'est d'être absorbée
et de perdre disons leur bébé bien sûr
c'est une peur qu'on veut absolument
éviter puisque nous si on vient
travailler avec eux c'est justement pour
conserver cet esprit d'initiative
tout en les faisant leur faisant
bénéficier des capacités qui existe dans
nos grands groupes que ce soit en termes
de données on vient de le dire mais
aussi de moyens d'essais de moyens de
producteurs et des expertises donc on va
à travers cette initiative et ce sera je
pense vraiment dans l'adn de sauveteurs
et public prendre le meilleur des deux
mondes entre les grands groupes
et les entrepreneurs une dernière
question pour relocaliser disons le
sujet on sait qu'il ya énormément de
potentiel sur un territoire en
particulier c'est paris saclay le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
aussi où vous êtes présent via le
technocentre qu'est ce que vous pensez
vous justement de ces territoires
comment est ce que vous avez déjà
identifié des potentiels sur ces
territoires alors bien évidemment
d'abord on est extrêmement large en
menant au ciblage de territoire c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas du tout uniquement
sur les grands centres urbains on est
sur des territoires ont validé comme le
plateau de saclay en périphérie des
grandes villes voire dans des zones très
rurales où les problèmes de mobilité
sont aussi très prégnant donc on là
dessus on a une large diversité et puis
effectivement quand je faisais je
parlais des ressources d'aidé des
acteurs
de la sauveteuse république bien
évidemment tous les assets de renault au
technocentre vont être largement utilisé
par par les start up merci eric falempin
merci à vous directeur opérationnel de
la software république pour le groupe
renault et pour plus avoir plus
d'information peut-être pour vous
inscrire rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
un nouvel équipement pour saint cyr
l'école après plus de deux ans de
travaux le pôle sportif pierre mazeaud a
été inauguré dans la ville samedi en
présence des élus et du principal
intéressé pierre mazeaud ancien homme
politique qui a été notamment à la tête
du conseil constitutionnel et surtout
alpiniste de renom le premier français à
avoir gravi l'everest en 1978 est le
pôle sportif est situé dans le nouveau
quartier charles renard et contient
plusieurs espaces notamment une salle
multisport de 400 places un mur
d'escaladé une salle de gymnastique ou
encore un pôle dédié aux arts martiaux
et aux sports de combat les propos
recueillis par mélanie poker la ville de
saint phalle école a une particularité
nous accueillant un lycée militaire
qui compte des infrastructures et nous
sommes bien classés en termes
d'équipement parce qu'il ya ces
infrastructures du ahly sanitaire sur
lequel la population n'a pas accès donc
il nous manquait un pôle sportif pour
pouvoir accueillir à la fois nos
nouveaux habitants mais aussi toutes ces
associations qui font un tissu très
riche sur la ville et qui avait besoin
de pouvoir se développer ce week-end la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
a célébré ses 30 ans d'existence au
programme de ces trois jours
d'animations et skate bm concerts
conférences ou encore balades en poney
coeur historique de la ville cet ancien
manoir du xiiie siècle entend bien
divertir petits et grands après une
année compliquée céline charles et
mickaël millero
30 ans d'histoire ça se fait d'abord
rachetée par la commune de montigny le
bretonneux en 1984 dans un état de ruine
la ferme du manet ensuite été réhabilité
pendant plusieurs années avant d'arriver
à sa forme actuelle en 91 en a eu le
plaisir de les inaugurer avec jacques
chirac
qui était maire de paris à l'époque qui
a eu la gentillesse d'accepter de venir
durant les trente dernières années la
ferme est devenu le coeur de montigny le
bretonneux puisqu'elle sait se faire
multifonctions auditorium espaces de
réunion grands espaces de verdure à
laquelle convention expositions soirées
ou encore team building c'est l'élément
patrimonial de la ville et c'est un
élément patrimonial qui vit puisqu'il
accueille toute la semaine les
entreprises et le week-end les familles
et il accueille aussi les associations
toute la vie associative durant ces
trois jours de festivités les habitants
sont donc venus célébrer ce lieu de
patrimoine qui fait partie de leur
histoire de quoi rappeler quelques
souvenirs il ya 30 ans mon fils qui
avait 11 ans dans plage de mon petit
fils m'a dit maman il ya j'accuse
monsieur jacques chirac qui vient
inaugurer la ferme du man et je veux y
aller on voit aussi à quel point la
ferme du manège à l'instant j'en parlais
avec une dame qui me dit ben moi j'ai
moi même mon mariage c'était ici est en
fait chaque signé mon teint à souvenirs
accroché à cet espace lac est l'occasion
de pouvoir transmettre ses souvenirs aux
plus jeunes c'est un juif
et
j'emprunte centre équestre suis allé
concert il ya beaucoup trop avec le co
vide mais effectivement il y avait des
spectacles né au spectacle
avatar les concerts une fois par an
l'école des musiques du manet tous
ensemble on a réussi à faire que bah ce
site reste le coeur qu'ils avaient été
soit son historique et bien qu'il reste
le coeur aujourd'hui de
montigny-le-bretonneux en espérant que
petits et grands puissent profiter de ce
lieu particulier pendant de nombreuses
années encore encore 30 ans de bonheur
de son côté le château de versailles
accueillait ce week-end la plus grande
reconstitution historique d'époque et
des centaines de passionnés en costumes
d'époque justement pour faire revivre
l'époque de napoléon il ya beaucoup
d'époque dans mon lancement en ce
bicentenaire et du décès de l'empereur
mélanie poké pour le reportage gare à
vous
porter
c'est l'heure de la relève devant la
tante du prince avant une réunion de
l'état-major dirigée par joachim murat
est bienvenu sous l'ère napoléonienne et
celle de la grande armée de l'empereur
j'ai fait partir par un aide de camp ce
matin des invitations pour certains
généraux afin d avoir à ma table pour
voir envisager avec eux le programme de
cet après midi leurs interventions
reconstitution d'instants militaires
mais aussi de vie de tous les jours
allez des métiers anciens et
démonstrations de danses d'époque de
quoi ravir les spectateurs
nous sommes ici dans le bivouac de
l'état-major mais vous avez également un
d'ivoire d officier de cavalerie à
mi-voix de l'infanterie vous avez des
artilleurs et ils tirent au canon à
blanc bien sûr vous avez des chevaux et
ont fait de la reconstitution de grandes
manoeuvres équestre bien sûr des revue
de troupe le petit est passionné de de
toutes les batailles napoléoniennes
notre objectif c'est d'aller à waterloo
dans quelques années pour justement voir
une vraie bataille en vo l'époque
les gens du peuple
des artisans
des soldats du terrain comment ils
vivaient
les batailles de l'eau quand la vie du
quotidien 400 reconstitueurs venus de
france et de belgique avaient fait le
déplacement des passionnés partageant
leurs connaissances clés tant que là que
vous voyez qui sont donc blanchet
revanche sont les tentes d'état-major du
prince murat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis plus de 20 concerts sur trois
scènes la troisième édition de l'eole
factory festival se dérouler du 10 au 12
septembre sur l'île aumône à
mantes-la-jolie mickaël millero et célia
gars tsongo ils sont allés faire un tour
pour nous
[Musique]
cela
c'est dans une ambiance conviviale que
s'est tenu ce week-end les halls factory
festival durant trois jours sur l'île
aumône à mantes la jolie une vingtaine
de concerts se sont succédé sur trois
scènes différentes
cet après midi là debout sur le zinc a
fait danser le public pendant une heure
c'est la première fois depuis deux ans
qu'on va jouer nos chansons devant un
public qu'on ne connaît pas et on
connaissait pas du tout ce festival et
on est très heureux de découvrir cesse
le cadre est magnifique des gens sont
hyper sympa et en plus il fait beau pour
ne rien gâcher à la fête
[Musique]
e
saxophone et clarinette font partie de
la fête puisque ce festival de musique
de mettre en valeur les instruments à
vent diversifiée et originale de mots
pour qualifier la programmation dès
cette année ils volent de la musique
classique en passant par le jazz la
world music il ya même des spectacles
enfants comme ce qui est actuellement
derrière moi donc il y en a vraiment
pour tous les coups on essaye d'attirer
le public le plus large possible sur 17
concerts 11 étaient gratuits les
spectateurs mais masquée mais avec le
pass sanitaires ou profiter de la
musique passe est merveilleux il fait
beau c'est très bien organisé
on attend on patiente c'est calme c'est
familial en plus tout le monde en très
grand sourire contente pas porter de
masque c'est coloré
il ya vraiment un choix de sommes par
contre ça c'est super chouette sur trois
jours de festival environ 3000 visiteurs
étaient présents
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi vous avez rendez vous
ce soir avec le 7-8 culture qui fait sa
rentrée et c'est avec célia gars de 100
go à partir de 18h30 belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]